We are trying out a beamer band. A beamer band is a PEMF band. It's a low-gouse PEMF band.
Do you recommend them? Why or why not? What would be the possible benefits for my
husband who has Parkinson's and myself? Stage 1 breast cancer, fully removed, no
known for cancers. Beamer sends a low intensity pulse electromagnetic field to the body which
enhances blood circulation by 29%. So yes, PEMF units are great. PEMF units are fantastic.
They're a great tool to help with everything. Just be careful with claims. So this, remember,
I said PEMF units are separated into really two, I think they're multiple different categories.
There's low-gouse PEMF units and then there are higher-gouse PEMF units. And it really has to do
a lot with the benefits that you receive. So low-gouse PEMF units versus high-gouse PEMF units.
Gouse is the output. So these beamer mats, the IMRS, there's, oh gosh, there's maybe a dozen different
brands out there that are low-gouse PEMF units. Now they can be extremely beneficial
because they're still putting out this pulse electromagnetic wave, but it's not even something you
really feel because I think the beamer uses about 700 gouse. That's the output of it. Versus like a
professional model PEMF, like the pulse brand, professional model PEMF puts out over 30,000 gouse.
So 700 versus 30,000 is a big difference, but you really pay for the unit, the price of the unit
is based upon the gouse output. So $5,000 for a beamer, and that's pretty good. I would check
into another brand called the IMRS, looks like that. That's a brand that's not sold through
multi-level marketing. I don't believe that's what the beamer is, and I think they're a little less
expensive than that, and they still put out the same gouse as the beamer. If you want to go with a higher
level gouse, we sell the PEMF that is a pulse for life brand, and it puts out the one that we sell
is 6 to 8,000 gouse, but you'll pay more for it, so you'll pay about 8,000, I think they're
8 or 9,000 dollars. So you really get, you pay for the gouse output, but for somebody with cancer,
somebody with a serious disease, you really almost need a higher gouse output machine.
So the low gouse output machines like the beamer or the IMRS, they can be good, but
part of the struggle that I say, be careful, the claims as they, they're still considered a
pulse electromagnetic field machine, it's just that they're just very low gouse output, therefore
they're a lot cheaper to make, therefore they can sell them less expensive, which I still think they
kind of want to price them, but I'm gouse output, you're getting 700, less than 1,000 gouse.
But then they take the claims of all the research that has been done at PEMF, and literally,
there is a slew of research done at PEMF, but it's all with the high gouse output machines.
And then they're saying, look at this research on PEMF, it increases the blood micro-circulation
by 29%. Well, I'm sorry, but that was research it was done with a high gouse output machine,
not the low gouse output machine. So they're kind of stealing research done on a very different
machine and then claiming that research for their machine, which isn't kind of honest.
So I'm not against the beamer. I mean, there's, it's still better.
Having a low gouse output PEMF was better than not having one at all.
So we have patients that have beamers, I say, good, use them, use them absolutely.
But if I wasn't going to buy a new one, I wouldn't buy a low gouse output one, I'd buy a high gouse output
one as high as I could afford it. You know, I can't afford a, you know, a professional model
pulse brand that puts out 30,000 gouse. Of course, they're 40,000 dollars, but you could afford
maybe a nine thousand dollar one, I don't know, maybe not. So, but look into it.
If you're going to buy a low gouse output one, look into some other brands, I think they're even cheaper than that.